Speaker 1: So in the midst of so many negative
and horrible things happening around the world,
I'm going to take just a brief break for something
that's admittedly not that important in the grand
scheme of things. I mean, listen, we've got
Ukraine. We have a shaky economy when it comes
to the stock market and inflation, although jobs
numbers are good, we have the resurgence of COVID
again. I mean, it yes. It's it's happening yet
all these different things. I get that what I'm
about to tell you is not of utmost importance,
but it's nice to have something good going on.
The David Pakman Show YouTube channel has achieved
and surpassed 1.45 million subscribers, meaning we
are now pushing very close to a million and a
half subscribers. Okay, now I know, Mr. Beast.
Excuse me, Pokimane. You know, these are major
streamers that make our numbers look small,
but we're not in their space. We're in the
independent left media political space. And
1.5 million subscribers in that space is actually
a really big deal. You've got the Young Turks,
our friends at the Young Turks
with over 5 million subscribers,
incredible achievement. They're a dramatically
larger organization than I said at one point. I
think they had close to 100 employees. I don't
know where they are right now, but orders of
magnitude, different size organization than The
David Pakman Show. We're tiny in comparison,
and yet we are riding up to being only the second
show in the left media space to hit the milestone
of 1.5 million. It's the Young Turks. And then, in
theory, it could be us if we get there. We're not
putting anybody down. You're right. I mean, if you
just look around, you look at other people in our
space, you've got a bunch that are over a million.
You've got some just under some closer to 500,000.
Right now. There is one major left YouTube show,
over a million and a half, and that's the Young
Turks. If and when we get there, we would be the
second. So this is hugely exciting and. Based on
recent growth, we're sort of on target to hit
1.5 million about a month before the midterms.
Should be right in the first half of October
is the way it's looking right now. However,
it's not impossible that we could do it way more
quickly. Right now, we're about 45,000 YouTube
subscribers away from a million. If we wanted to
hit that milestone by the summer equinox, June 21,
we would need about a thousand subscribers a day.
We've done that at other times. Usually it's like
right before a presidential election, but it's
not inconceivable that we could do that, even
just to hit by September 1st. That shaves about
40 days off. We only need about 400 subscribers a
day. That's very, very doable. It's only slightly
faster than we're tracking right now. It is wild
to look at old numbers and to see how far we've
come. The David Pakman Show launched on YouTube
in 2009. Thanks to Jank Yuga, many people don't
know this story, but in 08i met Janke at a talk
radio conference because at the time talk radio
was still big. Doing YouTube was the weird thing
and I met Jank and he said I told him what I
was doing at the time. We were doing a podcast
and a radio show and he said, I would figure
out just film to figure out how to film and
see what happens. And it took us five years to
get our first hundred thousand subscribers. It
took five full years just to get to that first
milestone. And then the next 100,000 took only
a year and five months, and then the next
100,000 was even quicker. And it's crazy that now
we might be able to add 45,000 subscribers in just
a couple of months and hit this insane milestone
of a million and a half subscribers. So I can't
thank you enough, everybody, if you're in that
1.4 or 5 million right now. Thank you. And I'm
coming to you for help and ideas. First, make sure
that you're subscribed. And second, if you have
ideas of how else we might be able to accelerate
the milestone, write in and let us know. Info
at David Pakman dot com. I'm always up for doing
something extra, something exciting and people
said at a million I should bleached my hair blond,
but we never got it in place. It was like we
were at like 990 when someone suggested it.
I don't know that anybody really cares about
that. I would be up for that and I would be up
for filming it. If it was interesting. We'd
have to put a challenge on it, right? Like
if we make it to the 1.5 million by August 1st
or something like that. But I'm up for whatever
people want to write in info at David Pakman
dot com. So let me know your ideas. We'll get
something in place and very, very exciting stuff.
Not the most important thing in the world, I
understand. But with so many negative things going
on, it's nice to have something positive going on.